caging dolphins is usually considered
cruel not if they're made of plastic any
dirt dolphin robot cleaners made by may
tronics in northern Israel are the
world's number one by some length the
biggest and baddest of mate ronix
cleaners is this big yellow on over here
it's the wave 300 XL it can clean an
olympic-sized swimming pool in six hours
this one's half Olympic size and if you
decide to take the plunge it will set
you back around eleven thousand dollars
among private pool owners may tronox
bots already have an air forty percent
market share sales are soaring and the
shares have risen almost threefold over
the past two years CEO you've albury
says there's still plenty of room for
growth we estimated the overall pool
business I mean there are about 21
million pools worldwide out of these 21
million pools there about between two to
three million pools clean with robots
today the potential is still huge the
southern hemisphere is still yet to be
equipped with robotics Brazil says the
area offers particular potential almost
all of its 2 million or so pools are
cleaned by humans at the same time he
plans to boost the sheriff sales
generated by pool covers and alarm
systems which can learn lifeguards when
someone falls in the water or gets into
trouble it's high-tech stuff but that's
not to say there aren't any challenges
macronix is about thirty percent exposed
to construction to new construction so
any downturn in the US or European
housing market would have an adverse
effect on me tronox results secondly
whether any any delay or prolonged
winter in the US or in Europe actually
delays orders within distributors and
could also have a negative impact from a
business for now though there seems to
be no stopping the march of the
dolphin's the company is aiming to
triple revenues by 2022 making members
of its parent kibbutz millionaires in
the process Elliott got Kim Bloomberg he
puts his rural northern Israel